[تصفيق]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه نستعرض معكم ابرز المستجدات وفي
العناوين
من محوري زابوريا وخيرسون اوكرانيا تحاول
اختراق الخطوط الروسيه وتبدا هجومها
المضاد
بعد نصف ساعه من انتهاء الهدنه الاشتباكات
تعود الى السودان ورائحه الموت تطغى في
دارفور
مسؤولون اسرائيليون الى اتفاق النووي
نواشيك بين واشنطن وتل ابيب تحذر
بلد اجمال حجم الدول العربيه تفتح شراكه
تجاريه مع الصين تتخطى قيمتها
430 مليار دولار
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه النشره المفصله
من العربيه الان نتوقف مع فعاليات مؤتمر
الاعمال العربي الصيني في الرياض ونتابع
ذلك مع الزميل لارا حبيبه التي تتابع هذه
الجلسه الانقطاع الخاص في العمل لاستقطاب
الشركات الصينيه ولكن اود ان نذكر ان خلال
القمه التي عقدت في ديسمبر وخلال زياره
الرئيس
والقمم التي صاحبتها وبدون تحضير يعني
كبير مسبق بسبب الاقفال الحاصل في الصين
خلال العام الماضي
استطعنا ان نوقع اتفاقيات بخمسين مليار
دولار 50 مليار دولار وانا اعتقد هي مجرد
يعني بدايه تدفق الاستثمار الصيني في
المرحله القادمه هناك استثمارات صينيه لا
باس بها وان كانت لا ترضي طموح وحجم
الاقتصاد السعودي الا انه ما شاهدنا خلال
الفتره القريبه من اقبال من الشركات
الصينيه سواء كانت شركات خاصه او شركات
مملوكه للدوله او الصناديق التمويليه في
الصين يعطينا انطباع
ان هناك تغير في استراتيجيه الصين
لمزج الصادرات من البضائع والسلع والخدمات
مع تصدير الاستثمارات وانا ما اود اؤكد
عليه
لاخواني وزملائي من العالم العربي ان ما
يقدم للسعوديه سيعم خيره الجميع ونؤمن ان
قوه المملكه الاقتصاديه هي جزء من قوه
وتكامل وترابط الاقتصاد للوطن العربي
الكبير
فما نستقطبه من الصين ليس للمملكه فقط بل
لمحيطنا العربي الذي سنرتبط فيه من ناحيه
النمو والرخاء ان شاء الله
اجمل استثمارات او حجم قيمه المشاريع
المرتبطه التي نفذت بالسعوديه المرتبطه
بهذه المبادره وحجم الاستثمارات تحديدا
التي دخلت الارقام لا تحضرين ذكرت الخمسين
مليار دولار التي تمت توقيعها كثير هناك
طبعا عده بنوك صينيه تعمل في المملكه ولها
فروع في المملكه وهي من اكثر المساهمين في
الاقراض المباشر
للمشاريع يعني سواء
فهناك ايضا تدفق في في مجال الاغراض هناك
عمل كبير بين
بين سوق تداول للاوراق الماليه وسوق هونغ
كونغ ونعمل ان يمتد ذلك الى اسواق شانغهاي
واسواق صينيه اخرى من ناحيه الادراج
المشترك لبعض الشركات في في هذه الاسواق
لتسهيل تدفق رؤوس الاموال لايضا
اسواق الاوراق
الماليه طبعا
[موسيقى]
يعني يمكن في الفتره الماضيه اكثر
استثمارات صينيه كانت في مجال الطاقه
بداتها يمكن اكبر استثمار خائن في الصين
اليوم هو في شركه ياسرف ينبع اكبر مصفاه
في المملكه العربيه السعوديه واكثرها
تقدما تم بناء بين شركه ارامكو السعوديه
وبين شركه ساينوباك هناك استثمارات
لارامكو وسابق في الصين
تفوق يعني قيمتها 20 مليار دولار
الطاقه المتجدده ويتحدث عنها زميل الاخ
محمد بنيان كانت مجال ليس فقط للاستثمار
الصيني
في المملكه ولكن كما سيذكر لنا انا متاكد
استثمارات مشتركه سعوديه صينيه في دول
اخرى في العالم العربي في وسط اسيا في
افريقيا يعني تمكن تنميه شامله ليس فقط
للمصالح الثنائيه
ايضا هناك ترابط كبير بين الخطط التنمويه
لمصر والمبادره الصينيه وخاصه فيما يتعلق
بتطوير محور قناه السويس والعاصمه
الاداريه
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد نبدا باوكرانيا
التي لم يمنع اشتغال الجميع بالتصدر
الفيضانات الناجمه عن تفجير اسدنا من
ابطاء وتيره المعارك سيما مع الحديث
الاخير عن بدء الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد
فعليا فعلى جميع الجبهات تقريبا يستمر
القتال في اقصى الشرق حيث تسعى القوات
الاوكرانيه لاختراق الخطوط الروسيه من
جهتي سابوريا اما في دنيا
بقصف المناطق اكثر من خمس وثلاثين مره
خلال 24 ساعه ودوا صفاره الانذار في ثلاث
مقاطعات الاوكرانيه يمكن القول اذا
مشاهدينا ان عمليات الهجوم المضاد جاريه
بالفعل نتابع
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا كما اشرنا تصعيد لافت في المعارك
في دوني ايسكو ومن هناك معنا مراسل
العربيه رائد الاغبر يطلعنا على تفاصيل
هذا التصعيد الكلمه معك رائد
احمد بالفعل هجومات اوكرانيه مضاده في كل
المحاور تبدا من زبروجي من بلدات اريخابا
وربوتينكا هناك محاولات للسيطره على اراضي
كانت سيطره روسيا عليها سابقا القوات
الاوكرانيه تقدم وتسيطر على اجزاء من
المرتفعات من اجل الدخول وطرد القوات
الروسيه من مناطق في مقاطعه الدفاع
الروسيه تؤكد بانها تصد هذه الهجمات وتكبد
الجيش الاوكراني خسائر كبيره
والقصف المتبادل ما بين الجيش الروسي
والجيش الاوكراني في خرسون على الضفتين
الشماليه
والجنوبيه مستمر في الساعات المسائيه وحتى
الصباح ساعات النهار تكون وتيره القصف اخف
لكن بالساعات المسائيه تبدا بالازدياد
وتيره وبالارتفاع وطيره القصف المتبادل ما
بين الطرفين الاهم هو مقاطعه
المحاور الساخنه جدا في مقاطعه دانيت حيث
ان القوات الاوكرانيه ايضا في محور باخمت
من الناحيه الجنوبيه الغربيه تخوض معارك
ضارة حول
بلدتيكا
ودخلت اجزاء من بلده كلي الشيفكا الجيش
الروسي يقول بانه يطرد القوات الاوكرانيه
من حدود باقي الاداريه لكن يعني المصادر
العسكريه تؤكد بان الجيش الاوكراني دخل في
عده مناطق في هذه البلده المحور الشمالي
من باخمت تتقدم فيه القوات الروسيه لانه
هناك كثافه روسيه للجنود الروس اكثر ما
بين سوليدار وباخمت وتحاول الوصول الى
بلده ايفسوليا هذا المحور الاكثر سخونه
لكن المعارك الضاريه والهجومات المضاده
ايضا حول مارينكا
هذه المناطق كلها ايضا تقوم القوات
الاوكرانيه بعمليات عسكريه مضاده من اجل
العوده والسيطره على نقاط كان قد سيطر
عليها الجيش الروسي ما زالت القوات ان كان
هنا المحليه او حتى يعني القوات الروسيه
من وزاره الدفاع يعني كعلان رسمي او
تصريحات رسميه تؤكد بان الجيش الروسي يصد
كل هذه الهجمات ويكبت الجيش الاوكراني
خسائر كبيره بالاليات وبالجنود نعم شكرا
لك رائد على كل هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل
العربيه رائد الاغبر
مشاهدينا مع الحديث عن بدء الهجوم المضاد
نتعرف اكثر على كل ما يتعلق به وبالتوقعات
الغربيه
لمحاور الهجوم مع الزميل فارس صلواتي اليك
فارس
احمد نعم بالفعل العديد من التقارير
الاخباريه كشفت على ان كيف بدات فعليا
هجومها المضاد على محاور عديده ابرزها
زابوريا وخيرسون فبعد ان فرض شتاء اسلوبه
في المرحله الماضيه خريطه المعارك بدات
تاخذ منحا جديدا ضمن استراتيجيه تتماشى مع
جغرافيا المواقع تسعى من خلالها اوكرانيا
لاستعاده اراضيها المواجهات مستمره سفاره
الانذار دوت في مناطق مختلفه في وقت
المحافيه الرئيس الاوكراني
بدء الهجوم المضاد فعليا دون ان يقدم
تفاصيل اضافيه
من المهم ان تشعر روسيا دائما بانه لم
يتبقى لها الكثير من الوقت
هذه المرحله لن اتحدث بالتفصيل
الهجوم المضاد الذي كثر الحديث عنه بدات
تتكشف معالمه مع سلسله الهجمات المتفرقه
التي ينفذها الجيش الاوكراني على مراحل
والتي كثفت في المناطق الواقعه في جنوب
شرق البلاد وفق شبكه فوكس نيوزكييف بدات
فعليا هجومها المضاد ضد روسيا حيث قام
الجيش الاوكراني بفتح جبهه منفصله جنوبا
في منطقه زابوريجيا وتمكن من اختراق خط
الدفاع الروسيه الاول اما في شمال مدينه
مخمو تحولت الخطوط الاماميه في المنطقه من
مركز الدفاع الى الهجوم حيث استعادت
القوات الاوكرانيه ما يقرب من 1400 كم
مربع من الاراضي كما تضغط والقوات
الاوكرانيه وبقوه في عده نقاط جنوبس بحثا
عن نقطه ضعف في خطوط الدفاع الروسيه وفق
ما اشارت له صحيفه واشنط في وقت سابق حيث
شنت العديد من الهجمات على محور دونيسكو
واطلقت 222 مقذوفا من عيارات مختلفه على
جولفكا وماكييفيفكا
الهجمات الاوليه التي تشنها يمكن ان تكون
محاوله منها لتثبيت القوات الروسيه في
مكانها وجعل الروسيا يلتزمون باحتياطيات
محدوده خصوصا وان روسيا قامت ببناء دفاعات
متعدده المستويات في الاونه الاخيره حيث
سيكون هدف الجيش الاوكراني الرئيسي كسر
الدفاعات الروسيه في الجنوب وقطع كل سلاسل
الامداد بين شبه جزيره القرم وجنوب روسيا
شكرا
رئيس مركز الاوراسي دراسات الاستراتيجيه
اذا يبدو ان الهجوم المضاد قد بات واقعا
الان لكن ما بين التصريحات الروسيه
المقلده من شان هذا الهجوم وبين التعويض
الاوكراني عليه كيف يمكن تقييم نتائجه حتى
الان سيد رمضان
طبعا انطلاقا من النتائج والمعلومات
الصادره عن الاعلام الرسمي الاوكراني
والاعلام المرافق هناك خسائر تكبدها الجيش
الروسي على المحاور الجنوبيه الشرقيه
وخاصه على محور يعني لاكثر من الف قتيل
وتدمير لاكثر من عشرين يعني معدات واليات
ثقيله بما فيها الدبابات اظن طبعا الدوله
الاوكرانيه
تتواجد في حاله الهجوم اذا طبعا فان نسبه
الخسائر سواء في الارواح او في الالياف
ستكون لصالح اوكرانيا يعني هذا واضح من
العلم او الاكاديميه القتال ولكن القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه يعني اخذت كل الزخم
الذي يتواجد لديها من معدات ومن كل ما اتى
من الدعم الغربي لتبدا في عمليات على عده
محاور لماذا على عده محاور هيا الان في
حاله جس النبض والبحث عن النقاط الضعف
للدفاعات الروسيه عندما تكتشف هذه النقاط
ما يعرف بالاحتياط من العمق الاوكراني وهو
قريب وعلى كل المحور او نقاط التماس على
مسافات معينه وتكون الضربه
لاختراق هذه المساله واوكرانيا تعول على
محور لانها تريد ان تفصل او تشق ماء او
تجد شرح فيما يعرف بالممر البري من العمق
الروسي الى شبه جزيره القرم وهذه يعني هدف
استراتيجي لخروج الى
النقطه او حق الاضعف لاختراق الدفاعات
الروسيه طيب لكن ما هي الاولويه بالنسبه
للقوات الاوكرانيه حاليا هل نتحدث عن
اعاده السيطره التامه على كل ما سيطرت
عليه روسيا في الفتره الماضيه ام دار نقول
محاوله لتحسين موقفها التفاوضي في اي
مفاوضات مستقبليه ربما
انا لا اظن ان اوكرانيا ستذهب الى مسار
تفاوضى في هذه اللحظه لان سياسيا ومن
الناحيه السياديه يعني هناك تصريحات سبق
وذلك من بخصوص لا تنازل عن الاراضي
الاوكرانيه حتى في المسار التفاوضي
الاوكراني تريد استعاده الاراضي ولكن انا
اظن ان الهدف من هذا الاداء الايجابي
نسبيا من طرف القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
هو الذهاب الى قمه الناتو التي ستعقد
فينيوس الشهر القادم
بشيء من الرصيد لكي تستطيع ان تفرض
اجندتها على الحلفاء الغربيين من اجل
الحصول على الدعم اكثر وكذلك تقديم ضمانات
سواء امنيه طالما لم تكن عضوا في حلف شمال
الاطلسي او تحصل على خوارزميه ثابته
بضمانات غربيه لتصبح عضوا عندما تصبح
اوكرانيا عضو في حلف الشمال الاطلسي فان
المساله القانونيه والسياسات تتغير جذريا
لان تصبح المساله حسب الماده الخامسه
ستجبر على التدخل اقول التدخل طيب الشان
الاوكراني لمجابهة روسيا يعني نفهم ذلك في
رمضان
من ذلك ان النتائج هذا الهجوم ستؤثر بشكل
مباشر على الدعم الغربي لاوكرانيا خاصه في
حال ناجح هذا الهجوم لكن ماذا لو فشل هذا
الهجوم الى اي مدرسه يؤثر ذلك على الحماس
الغربي في دعم اوكرانيا في المرحله
المقبله للاسف الشديد في حال ان اوكرانيا
لم تقدم لم تتقدم او لن تحرز نجاحا في هذه
المهمه اظن ان الغرب ربما سيبدا في
التفكير او جزء من الغرب نقصد هنا الحلفاء
بالتفكير لارغام اوكرانيا الجلوس على
طاوله التفاوض لان المصلحه الغربيه اهم من
المصلحه الاوكرانيه لان الغرب رغماتي
وليست لديه يعني عواطف بين قوسين طبعا فهو
يحسب كل فلس وكل دولار يقدم الدول
الاوكرانيه ولا يريد ان يصبح المشروع
الاوكراني مشروع خاسرا فلذلك الدوله
الاوكرانيه
يتفهم هذا الامر وسيعمل كل من عليه من جهد
وامكانيات لتحقيق النجاح على هذه الجبهات
والا فان الغرب ربما سيجبر الاوكران
للذهاب المسار التفاوضي وهذا ورقه خاسره
بالنسبه لاوكرانيا ولا نعرف كيف ستتصرف
الدوله الاوكرانيه حينها هل ستاخذ موقفا
احادي الطرف وتبدا في البحث عن تحالفات
جديده فهذا المستقبل كفيل ان نعرف بهذه
المساله شكرا لك من كيف كنت معنا اوراق
رمضان رئيس مركز الاوراس الدراسات
الاستراتيجيه تحيه السيد رمضان
مشاهدينا اعلنت السلطات لروسيا في خرسون
اجلاء سبعه الاف شخص من مرافق الفيضانات
الناجمه عن تدمير سد نوفك خوفكا واشار
حاكمير سالدو الى ارتفاع عدد المصابين الى
سبعه وسبعين واستمرار منسوب المياه في
الانخفاض واضاف ايضا ان نحو 1500 شخص لا
يزالون عالقين في مناطق الفيضانات وسط
محاولات لاجلائهم لمراكز ايواء مؤقته في
الاثناء مشاهدينا اكدت السلطات البلغاريه
عدم رصد تلوث في مياه البحر الاسود قباله
الساحر بلغاري بعد الهجوم على محطه نوفا
على محطه كخوفك للطاقه الكهربائيه وتدمير
السد مشيره في بعين الله عن عدم تواجد رصد
بيانات عن زياده مستوى التلوث في منطقه
البحر الاسود البلغاريه وبدورها اكدت
وزاره السياحه البلغاريه ان جميع شواطئ
البلاد نظيفه ولا تشكل اي خطوره على
السياح
رساله تونسيه للاوروبيين لن نكون حرس حدود
هلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد ايام معدوده
تفصيل السودان عن اتمام شهرين من الحرب لم
تعرف خلالها الخرطوم هدوءا اكبر من ذاك
الذي منحته الهدنه الاخيره ذات الاربع
وعشرين ساعه انتهت الهدنه التي حل فيها
الهدوء ما كان اصداء القصف والاشتباكات
والطيران الحربي وبعد مرور نصف ساعه على
انتهائها اكد مراسل العربيه ان اصوات
المدافع علت مع سماع دوي انفجارات في
الانحاء وكما سابقات ايضا مشاهدينا ركزت
الهدن على تامين وصول المساعده الانسانيه
الى المحاصرين من السكان وتقول المنظمات
الدوريه ان نصف سكان السودان البالغ عددهم
45 مليون نسمه هم بحاجه الى مساعده
[موسيقى]
هو قد عبر السودانيون عن املهم في ايقارهن
طويله المدى بين الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع مشيرين الى ان الاوضاع الانسانيه
وحل الازمه يستدعي وقفا اطول لاطلاق النار
التي تعلن هذه غير كافيه لايصال المساعدات
الانسانيه بمجرد مناورات
وفي حرب عبسيه اضرت بالشعب السوداني وهلكت
الشعب السوداني ودمرت السودان السودان
ثاني محتاج لسنوات طويله عشان يجوه ابناء
خلص ينجزون من هذه الوحده التي وقع فيها
والحاجه بسيطه يعني اتمنى اللي قدام شويه
اتمنى ان الله
واتمنى من الله ربنا يعني يخفف الحرب ده
والناس تبقى ترجع
الامور المعتاد يعني اتمنى انه
[موسيقى]
موضوع الهدنه تكون الهدنه فتره اطول شويه
نسبه لظروف المساعدات الانسانيه تصل لكل
المحتاجين ونتمنى انه الفرصه دي يعني تكون
فيها الفتره ما اقصاها شهر
اسبوعين ثلاثه اسابيع عشان الناس تقدر تصل
لمبتغاها الحياه الدايراها في الحياه
الانسانيه
المقداد حسن اهلا بك المقداد وماذا لديك
من معطيات حول الوضع الميداني في الخرطوم
واندرمان وبحري عقب انتهائمه الهدنه
نعم احمد الجديد هو تجدد الاشتباكات بصوره
واسعه في مناطق متفرقه في العاصمه الخرطوم
ابتداء من صباح هذا اليوم استيقظنا على
دوري قصف مدفع قوي جدا انطلق الى تمركزات
وتموضوعات قوات الدعم السريع وفي الاثناء
ايضا حلق الطيران الحربي وطيران الاستطلاع
وقصف عده مواطن في شرق النيل وبحر بينما
دوله المضادات الارضيه في مناطق متفرقه
اخرى في تمركزات وتموضوعات قوات الدعم
السريع بالمقابل ايضا افادت مصادر ميدانيه
ان الاشتباكات تجددت في شارع الغابه وشارع
واحياء الرميله والجوز ووسط العاصمه
الخرطوم بالاسلحه الثقيله والخفيفه كذلك
ايضا حلق طيران الاستطلاع في مدينه ام
درمان
والطيران الحربي بينما ردت مضادات ارضيه
من جنوب ام درمان على هذه الطائرات الجديد
ايضا ان المساعده الانسانيه التي
من اجلها كسرت حاله الجمود وحاله العنف
بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
لاربعه وعشرين ساعه لم تكن بالصوره
المناسبه التي تقابل الاعباء التي يتحملها
المواطنون في مناطق حلهم وارحالهم حتى في
المستشفيات التي هي تبعد من من المناطق
الاشتباكات بالكاد تكون تلبي حاله حاله
الحوجه والاعباء الكبيره الملقاه عليها
بالكاد تكاد تسير عملها جراء يعني من نفاد
الوقود ومن تعب الكوادر الطبيه المنهكه
التي هي بالاصل متطوعه كل هذا يسيطر على
مشهد المواطنه السوداني الذي يعيش داخل
العاصمه الخرطوم بمدنها الثلاث نعم هنالك
مناطق تشهد حركه نسبيه وحركه طبيعيه منذ
الايام الاولى للاشتباكات لكن هي الان
الان تتاثر بصوره واضحه ومباشره في في
تفاصيل حياتهم اليوميه من خدمات وكهرباء
ومرافق صحيه وكذلك من غذاء ودواء بالمقابل
هنالك اقليم دارفور الذي يئن بصوره
ماساويه وكارثيه للغايه نحن نتحدث عن
مقداد
على اقليم دارفور في
المقبله من هذه النشره اشكرك جزيل الشكر
من ام درمان كنت معنا الصحفيه المقداد حسن
تحياتي مقداد
من داخل مستودع الغاز
الان توزيع الغاز مجانا
والمحروقات
في المستودعات
شرق الكلاكله من داخل المستودعات
غاز بالجمله نهي بسرقه كل حاجه
مشاهدينا معنا الصحفي صالح ابو علامه اهلا
بك صالح وكيف انعكس انتهاء الهدنه على
الاوضاع الامنيه في دارفور وفي الجنينه
تحديدا صالح
نعم لو نعلميه في معظم مدن دارفور خلال
الهدنه كانت هادئه ولم تشهد عدد من المدن
هنا في غليل دارفور اي تجدد للاشتباكات او
الصراعات الوضع في الجنينه ما زال كما هو
الجنينه هي واحده من البؤره الساخنه جدا
هنا في اقليم دارفور الوضع في الجنينه
ابدا لا لا يكترث الى الهدنه وانما الصراع
هنالك متعدد الاوجه ومتعدد الاطراف الوضع
الانساني منذ الايام الاولى للاشتباكات ما
زال كما هو خاصه بعد تدمير المستشفى
وتدمير المراكز الصحيه ربما استمرت
الجنينه
يعني بهذه الحاله ربما تخلو تماما عن
السكان في الفترات القادمه اذا لم تتدخل
اي جهه لايقاف القتل المستمر والمعارك
المستمره في الجنينه بين الجميع معارك
الجنينه لا يسلم منها ابدا احد اليوم في
كل يوم
نتحدث عن المعارك المعروفه بين قوات الجيش
والدعم السريع ان نتحدث عن معارك ربما او
خلافات قبليه وايضا معارك تقف وراها
عصابات للنهب المسلح
نعم نعم هي هي
معارك يعني قبليه مسنوده يعني كما هنالك
بيانات تشير بان هنالك من يسند بعض
الاطراف في الصراع داخل مدينه الجنينه حتى
عمليات القنص التي دخلت في المعارك في
مدينه الجنينه اضرت كثيرا بمن يتجول في
الشارع من يذهب لاخذ يعني المعينات
المستلزمات المنزليه اليوميه الصراع في
الجنين هو يعني بعض الصراعات في الجنينه
صراعات قديمه لكن هذه الفتره يعني
الصراعات طالت حتى المعلمين الذين لم
يستهدفوا خلال الايام الماضيه الناشطين في
السابق لم يستهدفوا ابدا في الصراع في
مدينه
الجنينه صراع في الجنينه يعني لا يسلم منه
احد ابدا في هذه الفتره عمليات النهب
والسلب تطال جميع المنازل وجميع الاحياء
بغض النظر عن المكونات القبليه الموجوده
يدور هذا في ظل وجود الجيش وفي ظل وجود
الدعم السريع بالمدينه الوضع الانساني
ايضا يعني ما زال لم يتحسن وكل يوم يتفاقم
اكثر خاصه في مدينه الجنينه انقطع
الاتصالات ايضا ساهموا مساهمه كبيره في ان
لا يعرف العالم ما يدور داخل مدينه
الجنينه سوى بعد الاجتهادات من هيئه محامي
دارفور ونقابه اطباء الجنينه الجنينه تدخل
الان على اكثر من شهر وهي مقطوعه تماما من
الاتصالات ولا توجد اتصالات ابدا في مدينه
الجنينه هنالك ايضا عمليات نزوح مستمره من
كتب الى الفاشر خلال هذه الهدنه ما زالت
مستمره من المناطق التي شهدت معارك في
الايام الماضيه اذا من اقليم تبعنا الصحفي
صالح ابو علامه شكرا جزيلا لك صالح
اعلنت السلطات الباكستانيه عن مقتل ثلاثه
جنود وثلاثه مسلحين في تبادل لاطلاق النار
على الحدود مع افغانستان وقال الجيش
الباكستاني في بيان ان تبادل اطلاق النار
وقع في اقليم خيبر شمال غربي البلاد كما
انه تم تنفيذ عمليه بحث للتعقب المسؤولين
عن الهجوم وانه تمت مصادره ذخائر القتلى
من المهاجمين وفقا لبيان الجيش الباكستاني
ما كان يقلق اسرائيل يقترب ان يتحقق
بالفعل فقد رجح مسؤولون اسرائيليون تواصل
الولايات المتحده وايران الى اتفاق بشان
الملفات بالشان الملف النووي وفق صحيفه
من جانبها ابلغت الابيب واشنطن ان تهديد
العسكريه الجاد هو التعامل الامثل مع
ايران وفق الصحيفه العبريه ومن المحتمل ان
يتم التوصل الى اتفاقات بشان اطلاق سراح
السجناء والاموال الايرانيه التي تاخرت
بسبب العقوبات مقابل التزام ايران
باستعاده الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
الرقابه على المنشاه النوويه ووقف تخصيب
اليورانيوم
نشاطنا مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل
مخلفات الحرب في سوريا خطر لا يزال يفتك
بالسكان
من محور زابوريجيا وخيرسون اوكرانيا تحاول
اختراق الخطوط الروسيه وتبدا هجومها
المضاد
بعد نصف ساعه من انتهاء الهدنه الاشتباكات
تعود الى السودان ورائحه الموت تطغى في
دارفور
عن بعد
مسؤولون اسرائيليون يلمحون الى اتفاق نووي
وشيك بين واشنطن وطهران وتل ابيب تحذر
لحجم التبادل التجاري بين الجانبين
430 مليار دولار في العام 20 22
الدول العربيه تفتح شراكه تجاريه مع الصين
تتخطى قيمتها 430 مليار دولار
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد خلال مؤتمر
الاعمال العربي الصيني قال وزير خارجي
السعودي
العلاقات الثنائيه مؤكدا كذلك على ان
الصين تعد الشريك التجاريه الاكبر لدول
العربيه
باربع30 مليار دولار
زياره التاريخيه الناجحه لفخامه الرئيس
الصيني
الى الرياض في ديسمبر 2022
زادت من توطيد الروابط بين البلدين
الصديقين في كافه المجالات سواء السياسيه
او الاقتصاديه او الاستثماريه والتجاريه
والتي تزامنت مع اطلاق اول قمه عربيه
صينيه وقمه خليجيه صينيه والتي اثمرت
جميعها عن توقيع العديد من الاتفاقيات
ومذكرات التفاهم بقيمه تجاوزت 50 مليون
دولار شملت مجموعه من القطاعات المختلفه
كما الصين تعد الشريك التجاري الاكبر
للدول العربيه حيث بلغ اجمالي حجم التبادل
التجاري بين الجانبين
430 مليار دولار في العام 20 22
صوت مجلس نواب العراق على 18 ماده من
الموازنه الاتحاديه وسط خلافات بين الكتل
السياسيه داخل مجلس النواب بشان بعض
المواد المتعلقه باقليم كردستان العراق
وتحديدا الماده 14 بمشروع قانون الموازنه
والمتعلقه باقليم كردستان وعلى اثر
الخلافات رفع مجلس النواب العراقي فجر
اليوم جلسه التصويت على الموازنه العامه
واجلها لبعض الظهر مشروع قانون الموازنه
العامه مشاهدينا لم يتم تمريره حتى الان
رغم مصادقه مجلس الوزراء العراقي عليه في
منتصف مارس الماضي بسبب خلافات بين
الاطراف السياسيه لم تحل بشكل جذري حتى
الان وبحسب التقديرات من المتوقع ان تبلغ
الموازنه اكثر من 150 مليار دولار وهي
الاضخم على الاطلاق
مشاهدينا معنا من بغداد مراسل العربيه
سامي الكبيسي اهلا بك سامر ودعنا نتعرف
معك على ابرز النقاط الخلافيه بين الكتل
السياسيه في البرلمان العراقي على قانون
الموازنه لهذا العام
في البدايه صباح الخير احمد فعلا الخلافات
ما زالت مستمره حتى الساعه لم تحسم هذه
الموازنه هناك 68 ماده في هذه الموازنه تم
التصويت تقريبا على اكثر من اربعين ماده
اي بمعنى تم تصويت على نصف هذه الموازنه
الخلافات كانت تتمحور حول الماده الرابعه
عشر والماده الخامسه عشر الماده الرابعه
عشر وهي المخصصه لتصدير النفط من اقليم
كردستان
والعائدات الماليه الى الحكومه الاتحاديه
تم التصويت على هذه الماده وهناك كان هناك
مشاكل داخل جلسه يوم امس بين الحزب
الديمقراطي الكردستاني وبقيه الكتل
السياسيه حيث كان الحزب الديمقراطي يعترض
على تمرير هذه الماده الا بعد تعديلها هذه
الماده تم التصويت عليها باغلبيه اي بمعنى
رغم رفض الحزب الديمقراطي الكردستاني تم
التصويت عليها حدثت بعض الانسحابات وبعض
الخلافات داخل الكتل السياسيه ايضا هناك
الماده الخامسه عشر ما زالت خلاف حتى
الساعه وهي الخاصه بالتعيينات تم تاجيلها
الى اشعار اخر ايضا رئاسه البرلمان قالت
ان اليوم سيكون يوما حاسما اي بمعنى سيتم
التصويت على هذه الموازنه ظهر اليوم لكن
من غير المعلوم هل سيتم التصويت عليها ام
سيعاد سيناريو الايام الماضيه نحن على مدى
ثلاثه ايام واليوم هو الرابع ننتظر
التصويت على هذه الموازنه التي ما زالت
حتى اللحظه لم يتم التصويت عليها بشكل
كامل التصويت كان بشكل جزئي وصلت الى اكثر
من اربعين ماده تبقى نحو 28 ماده سيتم
التصويت عليها
فشل تمريق قانون الموازنه لهذا العام في
هذا اليوم الذي سيترتب عليه
احمد على ما يبدو لا يوجد هناك اخفاق او
فشل في التصويت لكن على ما يبدو هناك
تاخير في التصويت هناك اتفاق بين الكتل
السياسيه على تمرير هذه الموازنه خاصه وان
هذه الكتله السياسيه التي تتصارع فيما
بينها داخل البرلمان هي من شكلت حكومه
السودان وبالتالي اي فشل من قبل الكتل
السياسيه في التصويت على الموازنه
بالتاكيد سيكون هناك انعكاس على الحكومه
بالتالي حكومه السوداني تنتظر التصويت على
هذه الموازنه من اجل تنفيذ البرنامج
الحكومي الذي وعدت به من غير هذه الموازنه
لن يكون هناك اي تنفيذ لاي برنامج حكومي
الكتل السياسيه على ما يبدو انها باتفاق
على مجمل ما موجود في الموازنه من مواد
لكن النقاط الخلافيه تبقى مسار الجدل
وتبقى هي من تؤخر هذه الموازنه بالانتظار
سيكون هناك ربما اتفاقات بين الكتله
السياسيه تنازل من طرف لطرف اخر من اجل
تمرين هذه سنكون في انتظار مع كلمات
ستتمخض عنه الجلسه المقبله شكرا لك من
بغداد كنت معنا مراسله العربيه السامر
الكبيسي تحيه سامر
مشاهدينا انتهت الحرب لكن مخالفاتها تلاحق
السوريين مخلفات شكلت خطرا على حياه
مدنيين شمال غرب سوريا حيث تسببت بمقتل
اربعه اطفال ورجلين واصابه 16 شخصا منذ
بدايه العام الحالي ولم يتمكن المختصون من
فرق الدفاع المدني من ازالتها فما السبب
متابع
اصيب الدلال بانفجار قنبله عنقوديه من
مخلفات القصف في محيط قريه عرب سعيد بريف
ادلب بعد ان ظنتها لعبه كباقي العاب
الاطفال
مخلفات الحرب والذخائر غير المنفجره باتت
تشكل خطرا على حياه الكبار والصغار في
المنطقه حيث وثقت فرق الدفاع المدني منذ
بدايه العام الجاري مقتل اربعه اطفال
ورجلين واصابه 16 شخصا بينهم عشره اطفال
وثلاث نساء اصيبوا بانفجارات ذخائر غير
منفجره بمناطق متفرقه من شمال غرب سوريا
للاسف اليوم بعد 12 عام من الحرب ما زلنا
عن نواجه خطر مخلفات الحرب كميه الاصابات
والوفيات اصبحت مخيفه جدا بسبب انفجار
الذخائر المنفجر معظم الاصابات لما تكون
ضمن الاراضي الزراعيه ومعامل جمع الخرده
لازم اليوم نوقف عمليه الدخائر وخلطها
بالخرطه
جمع الذخائر ومخلفات الحرب لتفكيكها
وبيعها يعد خطرا يهدد الكثير من العاملين
في هذا المجال الذين اجبرتهم ظروف الحياه
الصعبه لتحمل مخاطر هذا العمل وهي مخاطر
اكبر بكثير من مردوده المادي طبعا نحن
بلشنا هاي من بدايه الحرب تمام من ضغوطات
الحياه وقساوه الحياه وهالامور هاي صار
معنا انفجارات صار معنا تفجير خسرنا خسرنا
شابين طبعا من بدايه الاحزان بدايه
معنا
لقينا قساوه كتير بهالمجال هذا تعمل فرق
الدفاع المدني على عمليات البحث والازاله
لذخائر غير منفجره في عموم مناطق شمال غرب
سوريا محاولين الحد من مخاطرها من خلال
فرق مدربه ومجهزه للتعامل مع هذا الخطر
ووقت فرق الدفاع الم دني
435 عمليه ازاله لذخائر منذ بدايه العام
الجاري جميع الفرق العامله في الدفاع
المدني التعامل مع الدخار والتخلص منها هي
فرق مختصه وخاضعه لتدريبات مكثفه لكيفيه
التعاون مع الدخائر
يحاول المختصون من فرق الدفاع المدني الحد
من خطر مخلفات الحرب التي لم تتمكن فرقهم
من ازالتها بعد من خلال حملات توعيه مكثفه
للتعريف بخطر هذه المخلفات على المجتمع
محمد الاشقر العربيه محافظه ادلب
مدينه ادلب الينا مراسله العربيه مسلمه
السيد عيسى اهلا بك مسلم وبدايه وبحسب
متابعاتك يعني ما الذي يؤدي الى عرقله
الجهود لازاله مخلفات هذه الحرب
وطبيعه ايضا الاليه المستخدمه في ازالتها
بحسب الجهد المتوفره حاليا والامكانات
المتاحه ايضا
نعم صباح الخير حقيقه يعني هذه الجهود هي
جهود محليه حتى اللحظه لم يتم تدخل بها اي
جهود دوليه مختصه يعني فرق الدفاع المدني
تتعامل مع هذه الحاله بافضل شكل متاح ضمن
امكانيات والاليات التي بين يديها لكن حجم
المساحات الواسعه بين مناطق النظام
والمعارضه وخصوصا الاراضي الزراعيه
الفاصله وخطوط التماس هذه هي الاراضي تمتد
على مساحات واسعه وبالتالي يعني تحتاج
عمليات طويله الامد ربما تحتاج سنوات حتى
يتم فحصها بالكامل هذه الحاله تؤدي بشكل
يومي الى وقوع العشرات من الاصابات نتحدث
نحن تقريبا بشكل وسطي بحسب الامم المتحده
عن خمسه اشخاص يقعون بين قتيل ومصاب
بجمع الخردوات ومنها ايضا مخلفات الحرم
نتحدث عن مئات العمال الذين يعملون في هذه
المهنه الخطيره بسبب الحاجه والفقر في
المنطقه وبالتالي هذه الحاله تؤدي ايضا
الى وقوع المزيد من الاصابات بينها
الاطفال والنساء
يعملون بجمع الخردوات كونها تتكون من
الحديد والنحاس والالمنيوم وهي غاليه
السعر هنا في المنطقه تقوم هذه المجموعات
سواء من العوائل الواحده اطفال ونساء
وكبار في السن يجمعون الخردوات من الاراضي
الزراعيه من المدن وايضا من المناطق
المدمره بالكامل
الوقت تعتذر منك لو كنت تسمعني من ادلب
مراسله العربيه مسلم السيد علي تحياتي
مسلم وشكرا لك
مددت اليابان مشاهدينا حاله الانذار الجوي
وحاله الاستنفار بالدفاعات ضد الصواريخ
الباريسيه وذلك رغم انتهاء مهله كوريا
الشماليه لاطلاق قمر صناعي وضعت اليابان
دفاعاتها الصاروخيه البالستي في حاله تاهب
الشهر الماضي وتعهدت باسقاط اي مقذوف يهدد
المنطقه بعد ان ابلغت كوريا الشماليه
طوكيو بانها تخطط لاطلاق قمر صناعي بين
الحادي والثلاثين من مايو ومنتصف ليل امس
من مدينه صفاقس الساحليه النقطه الرئيسيه
لانطلاق الساعين للهجره الى ايطاليا ودول
اوروبا وقف رئيس التونسي قيس سعيد ووجه
رساله الى دول الاتحاد الرساله جاءت
مشاهدينا قبل زياره مرتقبه اليوم لرئيسه
الوزراء الايطاليه جورج ميلاني ورئيس
الوزراء الهولندي ورئيسه مفوضيه الاتحاد
الاوروبي الى تونس لبحث ازمه المهاجرين
لكن ماذا قال لهم الرئيس التونسي قبل
وصولهم
هؤلاء ضحايا ضحايا نظاما عالمي للاسف
يتعامل معهم لا كذاوات بشريه ولكن مجرد
ارقام
ولا يمكن ايضا ان نقوم بالدور الذي
يفسح عنه البعض
ويخفيه البعض الاخر بان نكون حراسا
لدولهم لا الحل لا يمكن ان يكون الا
انسانيا وجماعيا بناء على مقاييس انسانيه
ولكن في ظل القانون
اذا قطع سعيد الطريقه على الاوروبيين بان
حل ازمه الهجره الى اوروبا لن يكون على
حساب تونس وهذا الملف بات يخلق اوروبا
اكثر من اي وقت مضى سيما مع ارتفاع نسبه
عبور المتوسط الى الضفه الاوروبيه وفي هذا
الشان المشاهدين وضع الدول الاتحاد قبل
يومين ضوابط جديده على قواعد اللجوء اثارت
موجه انتقادات واسعه المستشار الالماني
مشاهدينا دافع عن هذه التعديلات الاخيره
التي لم يتم ايقاها بعد منتقضا بعض الدول
التي تتنصل المسؤولياتها على حد وصفه
لكن ما هي الاصلاحات التي اثارت جدلا
اوروبيا في ملف اللجوء هو تعديل شامل
لنظام اللجوء الاوروبي تضمن التعامل على
نحو ملحوظ مع المهاجرين الذين ليس لديهم
فرص للبقاء في دول التكتل كما تتضمن الخطط
ايضا ايواء الاشخاص القادمين من بلادنا
تعتبر امنه في مراكز استقبال تشبه الحجز
وستخضع هذه المراكز لرقابه مشدده مستقبلا
وخلال ثلاثه اشهر سيتم تحديد ما اذا كان
لمقدم طلب اللجوء فرصه في البقاء ام لا
وفي حال تبين ان مقدم الطلب ليس له فرصه
فسيتم اعادته الى بلاده على الفور
عفوا مشاهدينا ومن اجل تخفيف الاعباء على
كاهل دول دول مثل ايطاليا التي تستقبل
غالبيه السعيد للهجره ينص الاتفاق ايضا
على اقامه نظام الزامي بتوزيع عدد متفق
عليه من طالبي اللجوء على الدول الاعضاء
في الاتحاد بولندا والمجر ومالطا وصل
فاكيو وبلغاريا رفضت دعم هذه الخطط في
منطقه الدول الاخرى هذا الاتفاق
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا بقي ان نذكر بالعناوين
من محوري زابوريا وخيرسون اوكرانيا تحاول
اختراق الخطوط الروسيه وتبدا هجومها
المضاد
بعد نصف ساعه من انتهاء الهدنه هل
اشتباكات تعود الى السودان ورائحه الموت
تطغى في دارفور
مسؤولون اسرائيليون يلمحون الى اتفاق
النووي نواشيك بين واشنطن وطهران وتل ابيب
تحذر
بلد اجمال حجم التبادل التجاري بين
الجانبين
430 مليار دولار في عام 20 22 الدول
العربيه تفتح شراكه تجاريه مع الصين تتخطى
قيمتها
430 مليار دولار
نهايه مشاهدينا في امان الله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات